Mark Cuban mAbs owner a big Steeler fan
growing up I think he went to Pitt and
then transferred to Indiana but a big
Steeler fan girl you know let me start
there with you mark how you feeling
about your Steelers this year I'm really
excited about the Mavs this year who was
your favorite Steeler growing up
probably Franco Harris because my dad
played poker with him one time just
randomly wait how did that happen I
don't even remember I just remember my
dad played poker with his buddies like
on Wednesday or Thursday nights and just
random people that you know his friends
would invite friends and I think Franco
thought he was gonna take his my dad and
his buddies for a lot of money but he
didn't realize my dad his buddies had no
money and that just was a conversation
so that was our connection to the
Steelers and so he was on my favorite
player and then obviously I remember the
Immaculate reception when I was a little
kid I mean I remember exactly where I
was exactly what I was doing so Franco
was your dad a Steeler fan oh yeah I
mean my dad I mean he we went to one
game because he got tickets from
somebody he worked with when I was 11
and that was like the biggest deal ever
and I'll never forget walking to the
game and that was the year that we won
you know when I was a kid that was
before they were good so it was the SOS
same old Steelers and I remember we went
and saw Roy Jefferson catch a touchdown
pass like the very beginning of the game
that was the last touchdown we scored
but we won and that was the only win of
the season so I yeah we were huge
Steeler fans I've dubbed until the day
my dad died when he was 92 he was a huge
Steeler fan what was that day like when
you bought the Mavs that you told your
dad you were buying the Mavs oh my
goodness um indescribable I just
remember you know just laying out a big
scream and you know and then when I told
my dad and you know it was kind of like
an impetus for him to move to Dallas
because he you know my dad did
upholstery on cars so if you had a rip
in a car seat then you took it to region
C products where my dad works
and he still was working and I couldn't
get him to retire and finally that was
kind of the impetus for him to retire
and come down to Dallas and live and and
just hang out and go to Mass Games and
yeah it was it was it was really special
also That moment when you make more than
your dad do you remember that I remember
when I made more than my father and it
and it bothered me a little bit like I
wasn't proud that I did I was sad it was
it was weird yeah I cooked like much I
mean I remember telling my dad I made a
hundred thousand dollars in the year and
he cried you know like I said he did
upholstery on cars and you know I don't
think he ever made more than $40,000 in
a year and it wasn't so much Dan that
was the hard part it was you know he was
dead and so like if we went out to
dinner he was pulling out the credit
card what and you know the minute I said
dad and he just looked at me like with
the death stare like don't even think
that you're gonna pay for dinner even
when he got to the point where it was my
credit card it was still the desk what's
the best thing you ever bought him there
wasn't any one thing it was just him I
told him he could go anywhere he wanted
to go in the world he and my mom and or
take my brothers and sometimes and so he
you know he loved to travel and so he
just got to go anywhere he wanted and
and he went on cruises everywhere he was
mr. cruise and there'd always be 20
stories and I I'd hear from people or
get emails from random people who made
friends with my dad and and yeah it is
you know I miss him every day but it was
I'm just grateful that I could just do
that for him he's Mark Cuban the Mavs
owner a season 11 premiere of shark tank
this Sunday night at 9:00 Eastern on ABC
do you know more about the new tampering
charges or more about the new traveling
charges or ruled about the new traveling
charges okay so I care more about the
tampering stuff you know the the legal
it will evolve you know like every one
of those administrative rules
it kind of evolved into the best format
and I think the tampering stuff it's it
wasn't as big a problem I think as
people as some owners thought it was but
I think they were just trying to be
proactive and so it'll evolve into
something that we all can live with so
I'm not worried about the tampering
charges the traveling thing you know you
had some guys who would take 30 steps in
a gather and so that's going to be
that's gonna be better you know and so
it'll be interesting to see how they
call it particularly you know even with
like Luca and his step back or hard and
you know it's supposed to be legal but
who knows how they'll really review it
and so yeah that'll be the more
interesting thing but can you monitor
tampering like can you really stop
tampering prevent it yeah if it's not as
prevalent look there's there's players
talking to players there's nothing you
can do there um because they're going to
be friends and do whatever in terms of
the what owners and GM's do that's
typically driven by relationships
between owner and agent or owner and GM
and agent and so as long as the Players
Association that regulates agents goes
along and and stays true to what was
passed then it shouldn't be a problem at
all I mean can you monitor it monitor it
no and then and and that's why they're
going to have the audit capabilities but
even then I just think teams if there's
a player's agent who's talking to
another GM you're gonna know right off
the bat you know if guys are showing up
at 1201 501 you're gonna know and so
it's it's going to be it'll be a period
of adjustment but I don't think it's
quite as difficult to manage as people
are saying daryl morey the Rockets GM
came out recently and said that he
looked at harden as the best score the
games ever and I'm paraphrasing but
basically he he's more of he's a better
score than Michael Jordan how would
Jordan do in today's NBA Oh in today's
NBA he'd kill it I mean his body be
fresh every night because it was just
not that you don't have Charles Oakley
you don't have Rick Mahorn knocking him
on his ass every time you you know went
into the lane
I mean you know Michael Jordan's
challenge would have been to learn how
to shoot three better and he's Michael
Jordan he would have done that just like
a lot of guys in today's game have
improved or three and so you know it
he'd be average in Jordan would be
averaging 40 in today's game you know so
but you know Darryl's right in today's
game as is Harden is the better score
because of the rules but if Michael had
been able to play in these in this game
a lot of guys not just Michael would
have been putting up 30-plus what is
Dirk Nowitzki's role now with the
Mavericks eating ice cream ambassador
just whatever he wants I think you know
he's adapting now to just not having to
get his body in shape and you know he's
he's still you know working through the
ankle injuries he had at the end of last
season he needed to get shots just to be
able to play those last couple games so
I think he's doing a lot of recovery and
Rehab work they're playing with his kids
you've got three awesome kids who are
now you know starting to get that age
where they're going to school and
everything so I think right now he's
playing mr. dad and he'll you know he'll
come in and and yuk it up with the guys
down to practice facility and you know
like I told them you know we've got two
things to do one work on the statue and
that you know that we're going to do and
and two is just you know whatever else
you want to do whenever you want to do
it there's no rush is that gonna be that
step-back jumper where the legs kicked
out is that the statue yeah yeah
probably but I'll let him decide I mean
it's been fun because I've been touring
around different places looking at
statues and trying to get a feel for you
know sculptors who have done some cool
things and then when I get past that
I'll sit down with Dirk and we'll review
all of it
when's the last time you beat one of
your players one-on-one probably when I
beat Dirk my first year really long yeah
so when I first bought the team you know
I was a lot younger back then and and so
I thought okay let's play one on one
dirt so he you know it stirred he was
just messing around with me so I scored
twice he stopped me and then he dunked
on me and I quit and so I didn't see one
but you got you had two of the greatest
shooters in the history game in Dirk and
Nash yep did you have a chance against
any of those guys if it was a shooting
contest oh hell no no but one day I
remember
you know anybody can get hot right I
mean I was 41 when I bought the team and
so you know I still playing basketball a
lot a lot more than I do now back then
and so I remember we were playing at
Baylor and Dirk and I were shooting and
shooting corner threes and I just got
hot as a pistol and everybody was
watching and we got up to like 13 and 14
in a row and Nellie said you know just
Nellie was our coach then he's like if
you can't beat that old you know what
then you know you're in trouble Dirk
and so finally he ended up beating me
but yeah I mean it was fun I mean look
one of the big the best parts of owning
the Mavs to this day is I'll go out on
the court you know 3:30 4:30 the day of
a game and I'll shoot and you know
there's always guys from the other team
that will get to the court early and get
shots up and I'll be out there shooting
on one half and nobody on the other half
and so we'll be able to yuk it up and
every now and then I'll get shots up the
last guy I did it with was Bo bond and
the next thing you know he's a Mavs and
so you know you never know what you
learn and who you get to talk to but I
remember one time Ray Allen came out and
I'm out there shooting he's like okay
you just use some you want to shoot for
money and I'm like no ray maybe some are
going in but I'm not stupid what moves
got more of your attention what the
Lakers did in the off season of the
Clippers you know none really
I mean probably what none of those
neither of those moves probably what
happened with the Warriors got the most
attention because the Warriors went from
being one of the all-time great
dynasties you know to being human and
you know there's a lot of teams now with
two stars and it's going to come down to
health and the ability to integrate new
players and I think the West is wide
open the East is always wide open both
the west now that the Warriors are not
so dominant I don't think it's I think
anybody can come out on top on Shark
Tank
are you buying into the business plan or
the person who is selling you that
business plan that's a great question
sometimes you know it's a business or
product that I just love and maybe the
entrepreneur isn't great but I know I
can help them and and get them to the
next level and then there's other times
where the entrepreneur is just so
phenomenal that okay the product isn't
quite where it needs to be or the
services
but you know but this entre more
entrepreneur can get it where it needs
to go so it really depends on the deal
but you know it's now the shark tank now
that we're going into season 11 this
Sunday on ABC
you know entrepreneurs know what to
expect from us more and so we've had to
up our game but they're just a lot more
prepared and so you see better
entrepreneurs and I think that that's
helped the deals and now it's easier to
make money from them honestly but when
there's a sports pitch it always feels
like you're obligated to at least feign
some interest in others
yeah I mean and when we had a rod on he
you know there were a lot of sports
pitches on typically were where I'm like
obligated is if the persons from
Pittsburgh Dallas or went to Indiana
University then it's like okay I got to
do a deal that's are just really not
very good or something I just don't like
so yeah there's times when they'll bring
guys in or women in knowing that you
know there's I've got to do the deal
unless they really screw it up it's
great to talk to you and hopefully we'll
catch up during the season Thank You
Marco appreciate it Dan take care buddy
Cuban shark tank and course the Mavs
owner for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]